Parlare nel Salone per un Fiorentino
dovrebbe sembrare normale
ma veramente non lo è.
È un'emozione incredibile.
E tanto più parlare di cultura dal momento che sono un ingegnere
forse è un po' presuntuoso però
visto che per tanti percorsi della vita sono stato coinvolto
con i beni culturali o se vogliamo
una fusione tra arte e scienza e beni culturali,
è vero, questo salone per me rappresenta qualcosa di più,
perché già dal 1975 mi ha visto coinvolto
nella ricerca del murale di Leornado da Vinci,
"La Battaglia di Anghiari" che si cela sotto queste pitture.
Vi racconterò un po' qual è lo stato dell'arte su questa ricerca.
Ma prima permettetemi di fare un po' un excursus
su quello che è lo stato dell'arte sì,
ma della scienza che cerca disperatamente
di entrare nel mondo dei beni culturali
per dare una svolta e certamente un contributo positivo
che potrebbe creare anche molto lavoro
e anche decisamente una valorizzazione
dei nostri beni culturali,
sia a livello nazionale, ma soprattutto a livello mondiale
visto che milioni di persone vengono in questo paese
non solo come visitatori, ma anche a portarci soldi,
non ce lo scordiamo; e forse questi visitatori
si meritano qualcosa di più,
almeno quando si interfacciano quando vedono,
osservano meravigliati e affascinati
i nostri beni culturali.
Io penso che oggi, se cominciamo a dare più spazio,
come ho detto prima, ai nostri beni culturali,
certamente questo può portare un modo migliore
per accattivarci questa loro amicizia,
questa loro dedizione al nostro paese.
E come vedrete si può fare molto di più.
Quando noi andiamo in un museo
pensiamo di vedere i capolavori,
siamo affascinati.
Però dovremmo anche cominciare a domandarci:
ma quello che vediamo è tutto quello che dobbiamo vedere,
che possiamo vedere, che possiamo apprezzare,
o piuttosto: magari c'è ancora così tanto
che quegli artisti ci hanno dato, hanno creato,
ma noi non riusciamo più né a vederlo
né tantomeno a capirlo.
E se riuscissimo invece a vedere il mistero che si cela
dietro la creazione di ogni capolavoro.
E se per fare questo potessimo usare
tecnologia, scienza applicata.
Certamente questo sarebbe per noi un grande arricchimento,
ma per tutti coloro che, come ho detto prima,
ci vengono a trovare e ci danno grandi possibilità,
anche economiche.
Facciamo un esempio:
prendiamo uno dei dipinti più acclamati, più conosciuti:
prendiamo Leonardo.
Pensiamo di sapere tutto di Leonardo,
diciamo che siamo appena all'inizio
a capire un po' Leonardo,
chi era soprattutto come artista.
E non solo per il mistero de "La Battaglia di Anghiari".
"L'Adorazione dei Magi" agli Uffizi:
chi è che può dire di non averla mai vista?
In effetti vi dico che non l'abbiamo mai vista.
Perché solo usando tecnologie adeguate
possiamo riscoprire, anzi scoprire per la prima volta
quello che Leonardo veramente ha fatto su questa opera.
E cominciamo a prendere un dettaglio
per vederlo non solo un po' ravvicinato,
ma se per una magia tecnologica potessimo rimuovere
questa pittura monocroma, forse scopriremmo
cose che sono lì, ma non abbiamo mai pensato
di poter osservare; per esempio la mangiatoia,
ma potete vedere che in basso sulla sinistra
si staglia anche la figura di un elefante,
che di fatto Leonardo ha dipinto.
Dipinto, anche se è un disegno, perché in effetti
l'ha fatto a pennello.
Cioè noi stiamo guardando sotto la superficie pittorica,
stiamo guardando il disegno,
quello che ci ha lasciato Leonardo,
quel momento creativo, che dalla mente
passa alla creazione di queste figure incredibili
oltre 70 che non abbiamo mai visto in questo dipinto.
Quello che bisogna fare è usare
delle opportune tecnologie
per poter passare questa pittura.
Ancora,
vediamo un altro dettaglio incredibile:
una raccolta di ritratti che, diciamo,
sono stati più o meno evanescenti per secoli
ed ecco che all'improvviso si rivelano a noi
e vediamo in tutta la sua grandezza creativa, Leonardo.
Una galleria di ritratti che non abbiamo mai visto prima
e non c'è nessun'altra testimonianza simile
di questa sua capacità, su un dipinto,
di creare così tante immagini, espressioni,
sentimenti, movimento.
Tutto questo sta lì sotto.
Allora quando vediamo un dipinto,
forse dovremmo chiederci,
ma è tutto quello che c'è da vedere?
E perché non proviamo allora
a domandarci, a diventare un po' più curiosi,
a creare questo valore aggiunto,
che sta in quest'opera d'arte?
Ma che per qualche motivo,
come è oggi la fruizione delle nostre opere d'arte,
nel migliore dei modi, è passiva.
Proviamo a renderla un po' attiva.
Proviamo a vedere come tutto questo potrebbe avvenire.
In questo caso, dettagli come questi
non devono sembrare magie della tecnologia.
Io ho cercato, molto modestamente,
di sviluppare insieme a ingegneri,
a degli scienziati bravissimi, a dei giovani,
come arrivare a capire la creatività,
come a arrivare ad apprezzare la genesi di un dipinto.
Senza per questo essere storici dell'arte.
E guardiamo se questo, in effetti, oggi è possibile
e in che misura lo è.
Video: Il tavolo HyperTouch
è una superficie tattile sviluppata da Kevin Ponto
nel laboratorio di visualizzazione del Profesor Falko Kuester
in collaborazione con il Centro per la Scienza Interdisciplinare per l'architettura e l'archeologia
dell'Università di San Diego e il suo direttore Maurizio Seracini.
Mette letteralmente alla portata delle dita dello spettatore
una visulizzazione interattiva versatile,
che permette di esplorare le opere d'arte con grande dettaglio
non solo la superficie, ma quello che giace sotto la superficie.
Dopo una completa indagine diagnostica
de "L'Adorazione dei Magi" di Leonardo da Vinci
le immagini multispettrali sono state caricate
sul tavolo Hyper-Touch
consentendo a chiunque di esplorare lo stato di consercazione
dei capolavori e le tecniche utilizzate da Leonardo.
Premendo con le dita sulla superficie si può rivelare
il retro del pannello in legno
e fare apparire i raggi x.
Poi la fluorescenza generata da una luce ultravioletta
che può svelare scie di polvere sulla superficie del dipinto.
E in questo caso luce infrarossa svela
il vero capolavoro dei disegni nascosti di Leonardo
che non si vedevano da quasi 500 anni:
i disegni preparatori dettagliati
sono stati coperti da questa pittura marrone
probabilmente da un altro artista così come indicato dall'immagine a infrarossi sudo color.
e altri test.
Sotto quello strato marrone.
ora visibili a chiunque possa cancellare via il passato
ci sono segreti sbalorditivi come l'operaio che ricostruisce il tempio pagano
precedentemente invisibile.
Nascosto da mezzo millennio
c'è anche una delle collezioni di visi
più spettacolari mai disegnati da Da Vinci.
Scusate per l'Inglese, ma questo è qualcosa che abbiamo sviluppato...
(Applausi)
all'Università della California di San Diego
insieme ad altre cose che più o meno vi fanno capire che
c'è un modo per sapere di più, vedere di più,
incuriosirci, ma più che altro farlo in maniera diretta,
attiva, interattiva.
E non essere più così passivi quando andiamo in un museo,
vediamo le opere d'arte, leggiamo i titoli degli autori, delle opere,
ma niente di più.
Dov'è il messaggio che ci arriva?
Dobbiamo riscoprire tutto questo.
E questo è uno dei tanti ruoli che la scienza può avere.
Ma non solo per le opere d'arte.
In Piazza della Signoria prendiamo a caso un edificio.
Quest'edificio, per esempio, è uno dei palazzi,
costruito alla metà del '700, che può sembrare,
non dico anonimo, ma certamente che non sembra rivelare altro
che quello che noi vediamo;
nel senso che anche per gli edifici dei nostri centri storici
c'è una storia, c'è un'evoluzione, c'è una trasformazione.
In altre parole, la nostra cultura che bisogna riscoprire
anche nei nostri edifici storici.
E c'è modo di vedere anche attraverso
quello che può sembrare il mondo del visibile,
anche sulle strutture architettoniche.
E questa volta usiamo un'altra tecnologia,
sempre nel settore dell'infrarosso,
ma un po' più spinta;
usiamo quello che si chiama l"infrarosso termico";
e vediamo un'immagine che di per sé
non ci sembra altrettanto significativa,
però se facciamo un po' d'attenzione,
vediamo che c'è un andamento obliquo,
quelle due linee lo indicano
come se ci ricordasse delle falde di un tetto.
Che vuol dire?
Vuol dire molto di più di una curiosità.
Vuol dire che abbiamo riscoperto
quello che in Piazza della Signoria era una chiesa
costruita nel 1000, poi successivamente rifatta
e ricostruita nel 14° secolo,
cioè abbiamo riscoperto un pezzo della nostra storia dell'architettura.
Abbiamo individuato una chiesa che ritenevamo distrutta.
Pensate di poter fare questo nei nostri centri storici;
edificio su edificio, ricostruire il nostro passato.
È anche questo un modo per dare un futuro al nostro passato
e per sentirci parte di questa scoperta,
di questa curiosità, di questa meraviglia.
Ma anche di questo si può rendere noi stessi attivi
nella scoperta, nella ricerca.
Permettetemi di introdurre un altro piccolo passo
usando una tecnologia che tutti oggi stiamo utilizzando,
ma per questo scopo.
Adesso date un'occhiata a questo filmato.
Come vedete, è un tablet: si punta contro la parete,
con le nostre mani sfreghiamo sopra
e si scopre quello che c'è sotto l'intonaco.
Si riscoprono porte, si riscoprono rifacimenti murari,
si riscopre la storia di questa parete
da quando è stata edificata.
Vale a dire dal 1497.
Anche questo, immaginate di poter andare nei nostri centri storici,
vedere le facciate, poter semplicemente,
con il palmo della mano,
cancellare quello che i nostri occhi vedono
e riscoprire il nostro passato.
Lo stesso, naturalmente, si può fare nei nostri musei.
Si può andare con un tablet e cancellare
quello che noi vediamo con i nostri occhi
e vedere la genesi sottostante.
Ancora, questa volta, abbiamo parlato del Salone, continuiamo.
Accenniamo un po' alla Battaglia di Anghiari.
La lunga odissea di questa battaglia che volgerà al termine
più o meno per le celebrazioni di Amerigo Vespucci,
del prossimo anno,
grazie fra l'altro all'interesse e alla volontà del nostro sindaco.
E permettetemi anche di farvi vedere
una piccola visione, breve, molto breve, del salone
acquisita con una modellazione tridimensionale a mezzo centimetro,
che è un contributo, non è solo una curiosità,
non solo per permettere a chiunque nel mondo
di poter vedere le nostre bellezze,
ma soprattutto anche come mezzo formidabile di conservazione
perché con questa precisione --
fra l'altro le pitture murali sono state documentate
con una risoluzione di un millimetro --
possiamo controllare nel tempo
l'evoluzione del degrado, gli eventuali spostamenti --
pensate solamente a cosa non succede sul soffitto.
E questa è una delle tante ricadute.
Non siamo nello spazio qui,
ma sono tante tecnologie che poi ricadono
sugli altri beni culturali.
Perché questo vuole essere lo scopo.
Ma vi vorrei fare vedere anche come siamo riusciti
a ricostruire com'era questo salone
prima dell'intervento del Vasari,
che è cominciato all'incirca nel 1560
e come era la Sala Grande,
come era al tempo di Leonardo da Vinci
quando si è accinto a dipingere la sua pittura murale.
Come vedete, era ben diverso:
soffitto molto più basso, c'erano delle finestre,
che oggi non appaiono.
E soprattutto non c'era questa ricchezza,
ma c'era Leonardo, che ci ha lasciato comunque
una testimonianza incredibile.
Tant'è vero che per oltre 60 anni
questo capolavoro veniva considerato e chiamato
la scuola del mondo.
La più alta manifestazione artistica,
mai raggiunta da nessuno.
E Leonardo era stato incaricato di fare questa pittura
come il pittore eccelso, a Firenze,
quando allora c'erano persone come
Michelangelo, Raffaello, Botticelli,
Ghirlandaio, Verrocchio e così via.
Vi faccio vedere a che punto siamo adesso.
Su questa parete,
perché è su questa che abbiamo identificato
il luogo dove è stata dipinta la pittura
cancellate per un momento,
immaginate di poter rimuovere tutta la pittura,
rimuovere tutto l'intonaco
e si legge ogni pietra, ogni mattone
per capire cos'è successo,
quali sono le trasformazioni,
dove dobbiamo andare a cercare e perché.
E fra l'altro, insieme ad una ricerca documentaria,
poi ci siamo concentrati sull'ultimo dei pannelli di destra
di questa parete est.
E in effetti poi abbiamo anche trovato
un'intercapedine tramite un'indagine radar
fatta in collaborazione anche con l'Università di Firenze
e con una società di Pisa
che ci ha permesso di capire che in effetti
in quella zona, è lì dove Leonardo
ci ha lasciato la sua Battaglia di Anghiari
ed è quella che andremo a scoprire fra poco.
Ed è più o meno questo che ci aspettiamo di trovare,
se non così, ma certamente nella zona
questo è senz'altro, anche dimensionalmente,
quanto ci aspettiamo di trovare.
Quindi, abbiamo fatto un excursus rapidissimo,
vedo che manca poco.
È il momento, più che altro, di indicare
alcune proposte che,
fra le tantissime, che potremmo attivare anche oggi.
La fruizione interattiva: avete visto pochissimi esempi,
ma quanto ci sarebbe da sviluppare,
sia in ambienti museali che anche sul territorio.
Cioè questa augmented reality.
Chiaramente vanno sviluppati,
ma vanno sviluppati anche i contenuti.
E questi si fanno con campagne di indagini scientifiche,
su tantissimi dei nostri capolavori.
Riscopriamo i nostri capolavori.
E usiamo la scienza per farlo.
Usiamo la passione e tanti giovani.
Sviluppo di tecnologie per la diagnostica,
per il restauro e il monitoraggio dei nostri beni culturali.
Ci sono tantissime tecnologie che potremmo prendere,
modificare e reinventare che già esistono,
partendo dalle tecnologie spaziali.
La creazione di una cartella clinica digitale.
Sembra ovvio, ma non è mai stato fatto.
I nostri beni culturali hanno bisogno
di essere trattati come pazienti.
Ma abbiamo bisogno di qualcuno
che allora li tratti come pazienti;
cioè abbiamo bisogno della figura del medico.
Che non esiste.
Abbiamo il restauratore, lo storico dell'arte.
Dov'è lo scienziato conservatore?
Dobbiamo crearla questa figura
e ci sono migliaia di ragazzi già laureati
che hanno bisogno
di avere il loro titolo di studio riconosciuto come conservatori
per potere entrare e poter dare il loro contributo
per salvare e valorizzare i nostri beni culturali.
E anche dargli delle funzioni e dei ruoli.
Tutto questo costa zero allo Stato.
E ancora non è stato fatto.
E poi il monitoraggio stesso dei beni culturali.
Non possiamo preoccuparci sempre e solo della nostra salute
e questo insieme immenso di beni culturali che abbiamo
lasciarlo andare come se fosse qualcosa
di impossibile da gestire
o come se "tanto abbiamo tante cose, una più, una meno".
Non ci rendiamo conto che questo
è il nostro vero bene, è il nostro vero futuro.
E la ricerca non invasiva preserva dei siti archeologici.
Oggi ci sono le tecnologie
per fare una mappatura sistematica
di tutti i nostri beni archeologici
che sono enormi e ancora non scoperti.
Ma anche sott'acqua;
perché dobbiamo aspettare che ce le rubino
e non essere i primi noi a renderci conto
di quanto tutto questo è importante
per la nostra cultura,
ma anche perché è un nostro bene.
E allora il mondo, a maggior ragione,
viene a trovarci, ad aiutarci, a portarci i soldi,
ma soprattutto a dare possibilità a noi
di creare tanti indotti su tutto questo.
Così come anche tecnologie dei nostri uffici esportazione
che, non si capisce perché,
quante opere d'arte ci vengono rubate,
ma anche esportate illegalmente
o semplicemente anche tramite canali illegali
e neanche lo sappiamo.
C'è tutto questo depauperamento di opere d'arte.
Dobbiamo riscoprire; dare un futuro al passato
vuol dire anche stimolare proprio questa curiosità,
questa meraviglia.
La ricerca, in altre parole, di una nostra identità culturale
che passa anche attraverso questa riscoperta.
Qui, proprio qui, si parlava di Uomo Universale;
cioè quel concetto di rinascimento dell'uomo stesso,
che però oggi, noi si deve riscoprire di nuovo
con una cultura veramente interdisciplinare.
Perché i nostri giovani hanno bisogno della cultura interdisciplinare.
Io personalmente non credo
che la strada sia sempre di più nella super-specializzazione
quanto di un allargamento di conoscenza e di cultura
che servirà ai nostri giovani per affrontare
le sfide di un mondo così eterogeneo e così complesso.
Grazie.
(Applausi)